The agents of the Naval Criminal Investigative
Service — or NCIS — often have to make
snap decisions when in the middle of dangerous
and intense situations.
Whether for the sake of their colleagues or
their country, several characters on the CBS
procedural commit morally ambiguous actions
over the course of its staggering 19 seasons
and 400-plus episodes.
However, when the sunny goth forensics investigator
Abby — played by Pauley Perrette — breaks
bad in a Season 5 episode, many fans consider
her behavior controversial.
While Agents Gibbs, DiNozzo and David — portrayed
by Mark Harmon, Michael Weatherly, and Cote
de Pablo, respectively — are characters
which openly struggle with personal demons
or family complications, Abby is a generous
and playful person.
But everything seems to take a sudden turn
in the episode "Dog Tags."
The episode kicks off with the team executing
a warrant on a house, only to find their suspect
mauled to death inside.
The suspect's dog Butch then attacks Agent
McGee — portrayed by Sean Murray — landing
a serious bite on his neck and wrist.
McGee defends himself by non-fatally shooting
the canine, but Butch's behavior convinces
the rest of the NCIS team that he killed the
suspect.
All except Abby.
Furious with McGee, Abby is convinced that
the dog — who she affectionately renames
Jethro — did nothing wrong, and she risks
her career to prove his innocence.
In 2019, on a comment thread titled "What
the Hell Abby?" appeared on the subreddit
for NCIS — a community which hosts over
12,600 members as of 2022.
A user took umbrage with an early scene in
the episode.
During the scene in question, Abby berates
McGee when she learns he shot the dog, and
doesn't believe him when he tries to explain
the severity of the attack.
While the commenter felt that Abby meant well,
they also claimed that the dog:
"[...] almost tore [McGee's] arm off and gave
him a life-long fear of dogs but she doesn't
show the slightest bit of sympathy to her
friend, and she never apologizes."
Numerous other Redditors affirmed that Abby's
treatment of McGee made little sense, considering
the characters' existing professional and
personal relationships.
Another user commented on the thread, saying
that Abby:
"...forces (more like threatens) McGee to
actually contribute for flowers for the dog.
AND LATER FORCES HIM TO TAKE HIM IN AS A PET."
Another commenter referred to a scene where
Abby tells McGee:
"Sometimes, you have to look at the reality
in front of you, and just accept it."
The user points out the irony of these words
— since Abby doesn't follow her own advice,
despite McGee telling Abby the truth about
what happened.
They exclaim:
"[...] this dog she just f---ing met is more
important than her friend, coworker, and ex-lover."
General consensus seems to be that even though
Abby eventually proves the dog's innocence,
that doesn't mean McGee should have to adopt
a semi-hostile animal who attacked him.
In fact, numerous fans revealed how Abby's
attitude in this particular episode started
her transformation into a selfish, petulant
person they didn't enjoy watching.
An August 2021 post on the NCIS subreddit
includes a comment from user who wrote:
"Cracked'' and “Dog Tags” [are] the quintessential
"Abby is a petulant child just cuz” episodes."
Just a few months earlier, an entire thread
dedicated to "Dog Tags" popped up on the NCIS
subreddit, the user wrote at length about
how the entire episode made them dislike Abby.
They voiced distaste for Abbey's "highly unprofessional"
attitude when the time came to surrender the
dog, and went on to detail their distaste
for how Abby completely neglects McGee's feelings.
The post elicited a comment from another user
that appears to best sum up the entire issue
with "Dog Tags" and the way it depicts Abby:
"I always loved early seasons Abby but as
the show progressed I felt like she got more
selfish, childish, and unprofessional.
It was a weird regression, like they tried
too hard to make her quirky."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about NCIS are
coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.